Hi,
I'm Marissa Meyer and I'm really excited today to be joined by the world famous,
incredibly talented,
the one and only lady Gaga
[inaudible]
at Google.
We've seen goggle build her career by embracing technology,
including some,
some Google tools as well as constantly innovating for her fans.
And we're going to get a glimpse behind the scenes to see how some of that
innovation works today.
But first I'd like to play a video to welcome God.
Go onto Google.
Yeah,
no,
yes.
[inaudible]
yeah,
the new wheel chairs are a little high.
I hear so much for coming.
This is going to put my purse weight.
Yeah,
I love you too.
Hi everyone.
Can you just get out of jail?
Yeah,
me too.
Uh,
uh,
we are so excited
to have you here
and I'm so excited to be here.
I just want to say before we even begin,
thank you so much.
This is such an honor.
Uh,
you know,
when I was in high school,
all my girlfriends wanting to get jobs here
and,
um,
I wanted to be what they were searching for or putting on the,
you know,
the side column would comes up first.
I believe that's what my friend Mary Hurley does here at Google.
But uh,
so just thank you so much for coming and I really,
um,
I respect all of you so much.
I know that there's some really amazing minds in this room and how competitive
it is.
So thank you.
[inaudible].
Speaking of searches,
you are among the most searched people in the world,
even on the top.
And we're at 2009 and 2010 fastest rising searches.
We made a portrait here of you taking the millions of searches that had come in
for lady Gaga.
Beautiful.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
obviously you've been a huge search star,
also a huge youtube star,
bad romance.
It has 316 million views.
Just that one video,
Andrew,
the queen of the download.
You're actually the most downloaded artist in history with more than 20 million
singles downloaded.
It's amazing.
Thank you.
All of which brings us to today.
So last week you opened up a moderator page on your Youtube Channel and you got
questions from your fans.
54,000 questions and more than a quarter million votes in just three and a half
days.
We have questions that are both in text and video.
I bought the top 20 questions here.
We're going to go through those and then also do some questioning,
the same dress
branding.
So the first question I'm going to ask can you came in in video form,
but it was also going to be my first question.
Uh,
it comes in from a user,
a certain resonance and we'll go ahead and roll that video question.
Well,
my first question that I wanted to ask was how are you,
I remember in one of your interviews you said that that was a question that
interviewers never really asked you and actually meant it.
And so I wanted to ask you and actually mean it.
So how are you?
Wow.
I am absolutely wonderful and a little bit choked up because that is why I am
still here and why I worked so hard.
It's because I really am very blessed to have fans with such a beautiful spirit.
And I'm sure you can see just from that one video very much what a lot of my day
is like.
I do spend a lot of time on Google looking for a fan videos and messages and I'm
doing wonderful today.
And I wouldn't say that,
um,
the only reason I ever mentioned that people don't ask me how I am genuinely is
because it took a lot of bravery to get to where we are today.
Uh,
a lot of people see glasses and shoulder pads and crazy outfits.
And um,
over the years it was very difficult to do interviews because that's all people
would talk about.
So I guess what I would say is I'm doing wonderful now because of how brave that
all my fans have made me.
So thank you for making me brave and I hope I can.
Thank you.
Break.
You're also on tour,
so you're performing tonight in Oakland
hairdo going,
uh,
and what the next question is about your tour.
So Gong on fame 11 from the UK asks,
do you have any funny stories to tell about things that had happened backstage
at the monster ball?
There are lots of funny things that happened backstage at the monster ball.
Um,
I don't like surprises and I don't like pranks natural.
I'm sure you can maybe tell her that's fine
when I don't like pink.
But,
um,
I actually with me,
I brought all my friends from New York City on tour with me.
So I have had very few,
I should say famous,
uh,
acts opening.
It's been mostly a really underground bands and Djs and I've known since I was
18 years old.
So there's a lot of backstage shenanigans.
Very often they make jokes about my diet cause they know I have to say stay fit
for music videos.
So they'll leave like mountains and cheeseburgers and stuff in my dressing room.
Vicious.
Uh,
so going back to before the cheeseburgers where you got your star wars,
one of your fans,
Mr Gold,
Maddie from California asks,
where were you the first time you heard one of your songs on the radio?
I was in Canada.
I know,
never,
I
forget it,
but it's a very different,
it's funny.
It's almost more enjoyable now when I hear it for the first time on the radio
because at the time in Canada I had,
I mean,
many people don't know this about me because it seems as though one just stands
at number one.
It was this big massive,
oh,
she became a star overnight.
But to tell you the truth,
I hadn't been working so hard doing three shows at night.
Uh,
oh all day long.
Going to radio stations doing of a phone or as my,
the reason we're here on Google today is because the original campaign for my
music and my project began with online,
uh,
and meeting based,
advertisement.
So,
uh,
that's really where I began.
So I remember was in Canada and I was really tired and I was about to go on
stage at this outdoor,
um,
uh,
performance.
I actually think it wasn't winning pain,
which is why we aren't gonna smell it from the video.
And,
um,
I remember I heard it and I started crying and my tour manager,
David said,
how does it feel?
And I said,
damn tie.
And so now when it comes on,
it's a little bit more of a gracious,
humbling.
Well,
so in terms of other special moments,
a Song Adelaide from Sheffield,
England ass when exactly it was that moment in your career when you realized you
were going to be an international superstar.
I still don't feel like one
really like possible.
I just,
I know that sounds very silly,
but um,
even this morning I was getting ready to Ted tweet that I was coming here today
and I got like 50 freaking emails.
Like don't tweet it.
It,
they don't want anyone to know.
[inaudible]
well I guess,
I guess they were worried
for security,
but I need him.
I need to market when workers,
you know,
people need
no,
and so everyone was saying,
well they know you're going to be there and just don't tell them when.
And I,
and Oh my gosh,
my security is always,
they want to shoot me because I will literally leave the house and go to the
Bodega down the street where I live in New York.
And they're like,
where?
All right.
Because where I live,
I haven't been hustling for so long that it's more just like your home,
you know,
like everybody's so cool.
And I guess even though my first album was called a beam,
that was never the ultimate goal of any of this.
It was always that I just really am genuinely a musician to my core.
And a lot of people don't know that about me,
but I write every lyric and we,
Melanie,
I'm in there with a producer's whipping them to make the new future of music.
And I,
that is why I'm here.
I'm not here.
Took me a superstar.
But,
so yes and no.
I,
I never,
ever,
there was never a day when I woke up and said,
I'm a superstar.
I'm still waiting for that to happen.
Fair enough.
So in terms of formative experiences,
um,
hugs and kisses,
x o x o 94 from Pennsylvania asks,
okay,
you said that in school a lot of people bullied you and didn't like you.
Now that you're famous heaven,
you can try to quote unquote apologize,
become friends.
And so when did you say to them?
Yeah,
I wouldn't say apologize.
There's been lots of concert ticket with us.
Okay.
Um,
and I think one of the most awkward things that anyone ever said to me was,
um,
well my,
my,
how the tables have turned.
Um,
but to be honest site,
I don't have that kind of binge fall spirit and myself and I never did.
And it was just more that,
you know,
and I say this with so much,
Jay,
you know,
genuine is from like my heart is it bullying really stays with you your whole
life.
And it really,
really never goes away.
And I know you're using words like superstar and most googled and billions of
youtube videos,
but I was never,
the winter I was always the loser and,
uh,
that's still stays with me.
And,
uh,
do I want to stick it to anybody?
No,
I just want to make music.
So,
uh,
[inaudible]
and well I do think,
I think bullying is a really big issue right now,
especially to him.
MMM.
I'm listening.
Okay.
I imagine that born this way is a little bit about being yourself and how to
overcome bullies.
And I don't know if you want to talk a little bit,
a little bit,
what's so funny
that song out because everybody was like,
oh,
the lyrics are so literal.
And I'm like,
yeah,
when you know,
when you get bullied you kind of try to,
there's almost this like emotional poetry that you go through in high school.
Oh well,
Sunday.
And he just couldn't turn a high from it and be the bigger person.
But born this way is about saying this is who I am,
this is who the fuck I am.
I mean the next single Judas is like this very classic Gaga record.
But more importantly,
the song born this way is this like gateway drug for the album.
And really trying to say in the most literal and honestly that I can,
that when I go to the monster ball,
I see somethings so fearless and so special in my fans,
but I also see something afraid.
It's something that I was sending that I was unsure and I really encourage
people to look into the darkness and look into places that you would not
normally look to find uniqueness and specialists because that's where that the
diamonds are hiding,
I think.
Awesome.
MMM,
and you were actually,
I'm around very classically trained pianist,
jazz musician and one of our video questions from Leopard scholar 20 actually is
about your market.
You've got a little bit in the and Scar Libre scar 20 wants to know about your
training ongoing.
So we'll go ahead and roll that video.
There you go.
Done.
This is Rudy Hernandez,
one of your little monsters from Portland,
Oregon.
My question is is I was just wondering if you still took piano training in vocal
training to improve your skills.
It'd be great to hear you answer my question.
I can't wait to see you again here in Portland,
Oregon.
And pause.
Hi Katie.
Um,
uh,
yes,
I am
Shelly vocally rehearse every single day,
nine to eight 30 minute warm up every single day.
Uh,
it's been the same vocal warmup that I've been doing since I was 11 years old.
I've been,
I'm hitting my mentor,
Don Lawrence,
uh,
has been my voice teacher since I was 11,
so it's over 10 years now.
Um,
and in terms of piano,
um,
Panas funny.
I mean it's kind of the thing that always stays with you.
I don't know if there's any penis in this room,
uh,
but if you don't practice for a little while and then you focus on it,
you kind of get your jobs back pretty quickly.
So I,
what I do mostly for a piano is I tried to find time when I'm in New York City
or on the road to do shows and have jam sessions with my band just for fun.
So whenever you see those really Horton photos of me looking drunk on a piano
bar,
uh,
I'm actually
okay.
Ah,
that's just how I like to rehearse.
I like to have a couple of words teenies and play some Cole Porter.
And that's just the way I like to learn.
Yeah.
But it was day in school.
So changing,
changing gears a little bit.
I actually have a confession to me.
So we'll pull a picture up here.
I was new for a Halloween in 2009 I want to see it
and you can see your parents.
Nah,
fabulous on my hands.
And look at cheese.
So I guess transitioning to your style is inspired so many people and
no,
what is it about?
Is it because it's a blonde
blonde and I actually am,
I am stars on my face,
the long island.
Oh,
I see the side of,
there's no poker chips on my hat
for poker face.
So,
okay.
so many people beyond just me and millions of people have been inspired by your
style.
Uh,
and one of the other fans would like to know is Sore Gaga official.
Sir Gaga would like to know with all the clothes you have,
how do you decide what to wear every day and what happens to the garments after
their warm?
Um,
how do I decide what to wear?
It's actually not quite as complicated as some of you might imagine.
Um,
I sometimes,
I mean I'll,
I'll plan months ahead for certain things.
Uh,
that I,
for example,
at the grammys,
the,
um,
the Hussein Chalayan Bessel,
although it's become known as the egg,
he wants me to mind you.
It's the vessel.
Uh,
that was,
that took months and months of conception and I wanted to do a whole performance
art piece that began on the red carpet and ended after the performance.
So certain things take a while and yes,
I do view the vessel as a fashion piece.
Uh,
but like today,
um,
I wore the same black dress because I wanted the fans to recognize me a certain
way when I entered the Google building
and also on the topic of style and you have tattoos and one of the other fans
noticed that they're all on your left side.
So Taylor,
Monster 15,
like to know why are all of your tattoos on the left side of your body?
It was actually parent my father's request.
So tell us more ass that
I remain on one side,
slightly normal.
So I only have my attention is on my left side.
Uh,
I don't,
I'm also a lefty,
so,
um,
it's funny,
my father,
when I was a kid,
he used to try to change my hands when I was little and the doctor would be
like,
she was born that way.
You can't.
Uh,
so I think maybe some of it just from a neurological standpoint,
it might be because I'm creatively driven by my left side.
And maybe that's why.
But he's at,
he's asked that I don't get any more on the rates side for whatever reason.
I think he sees this as my,
like Marilyn Monroe side.
And this is my ag passe.
Yeah.
So be under silent close and tattoos.
You also has shown tremendous style and your videos and the Struby do would like
to know how do you come up with your video ideas?
Every time I watch that,
I'm stunned by the creativity and meaning.
I love you get lady Gaga.
Struby Dude,
you're a little monster.
Three.
We do.
Struby do.
Okay.
Um,
it's just good old faithful.
I'm a creative person and I just always at some point the idea comes to me and
the most important thing I think with creativity is that you honor your
creativity and that you don't ever ignore it or um,
uh,
go against what,
that creative image is telling you because of what society is projecting on you.
I remember when I called Troy Carter,
my manager from Amsterdam and I was like,
I want to be on a government owned alien territory and space and I wouldn't be
giving birth to my own head.
I just want to ask about the clients.
You know,
you hear them.
Ooh.
And he was like,
why?
And I said,
because I see myself and my fans and I feel that they give birth to me and I
give birth to them and the AA symbolized the race of the future,
which oppose no prejudice.
So you know,
I have my own and I'm like,
then I was showing him Francis Bacon photos,
which is like all this like,
you know,
bleeding imagery.
And he was like,
I don't get it.
You know,
we worked with Nick Knight on that video.
If you think I'm bad and McKnight is woo,
he is so smart.
I'm just like nick,
I love you but I don't understand what you're saying.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
I just really always like just the other night,
last night actually I was laying in bed and I had this idea for an outfit and I
just made myself get up and I sketched it real fast and then I went back to
sleep.
I think it's when you say,
Oh,
I'm too tired,
let me just go to bed.
That's when the creativity stops stops coming.
And when you,
you know,
if God calls you pick up the damn phone.
Hello.
So on the topic of videos,
you've obviously shared youtube star.
I was going to ask and so it was dark,
dark of USA from Kentucky.
What's your favorite youtube video that isn't yours?
My favorite youtube video that
it's so embarrassing,
but I love it.
I love the boy.
But when he comes home from the dentist,
Aye.
Play always sick.
Whenever I'm really tired before I use this show,
I always go,
is this real lie?
Okay.
Because I'll have been up for like 30 hours straight during interviews and then
I'll hear the,
you know,
did it dent
and it shows darts and I just go,
is this real life?
Everybody knows it is.
I love that mini boy.
There's also so many fan remixes and remakes IB your songs
on Youtube.
I was wondering if you have a favorite thing or,
I know there's Maria,
the young girl I think really embodies a lot of what is interesting about
technology.
Maria is just so special and you know,
she's,
she's like 10 years,
she's 10 years old,
but even 10 year olds today,
I know how to work a web cam and uploading youtube video.
You know?
And I think that's the,
that is why this for myself,
my campaign and with my album has been so successful is because I too am a child
of the.com era.
I mean my father ran an internet company when I was really young,
so I was listening to lots of technology talk jargon over the dinner table.
Not Understanding till lunch later what it all meant.
Uh,
but,
uh,
she's beautiful.
She's very young and she has a voice in the world and she latched on to a song
that was very risky for me to put out a so soon and my career.
Uh,
but if I could just touch maybe 10,
10 year olds in the world and every single continent,
maybe I could make a difference
there.
We have the Maria video.
I think it would be good for people to stay ahead.
I think I may have a coupon.
Oh,
she say
great.
Oh
yeah.
Was this way
amazing.
It's,
so what I would like to speak about is the way that we experience music now.
We experienced the music thing.
The Internet has really great effects and it also has really negative effect.
The great effect is Maria,
the negative effect is you sort of quite mathematically input your songs and
your soul into a computer and out spits out charts.
So
like the fan experience now,
um,
digitally is they buy in the song and then they get into chat rooms and they
watch the song climate chart.
But somebody like Maria has no pretension.
She's wildly innocent and beautiful and she only cares about the music and the
lyrics.
So when I'm working on doing now is creating a fan experience with the release
of born this way that takes them a bit away from the computer in terms of the
actual purchase of the song.
Uh,
I want to encourage the fans to experience the music and the lyrics.
Um,
we moved of,
uh,
that sort of behind the computer.
Um,
uh,
banter.
When I was a kid,
I was standing outside of h and the praying that I saw Billy Joe's fingernail
and the window,
uh,
going to get my green day CD signed.
I was hoping that I would see Tongue York when Radiohead came in,
you know,
that is what I want to recreate from my fans.
We've done it with the monster mall and now I want to do it,
uh,
with album retail.
And you're also showing a lot of things from behind the scenes.
So you hadn't gone vision on Youtube and go,
I got info from Twitter.
Would like to know.
Please could you bring back Gaga Vision?
We miss it so much.
Ps,
we love you and we're so proud.
I love Gaga Vision.
Uh,
that was the,
they were these little films that I was doing,
uh,
back when I first began,
touring.
But I actually just got so busy,
um,
it was really difficult to have a camera in my face.
You will never see me do reality television.
It will never don't even app.
Whenever it happened,
it will never happen.
It's just,
um,
I'm not that kind of person.
Uh,
life whole life is a performance piece.
So I don't need to have my picture taken to feel that I'm in a moment of art.
So,
uh,
but the good news is as I'm planning the born this way ball,
I have been speaking at Terry Richardson,
who's this really amazing photographer.
He wanted to,
uh,
film some of them making a process of what we're doing.
So I'm hoping we can resurrect the Gaga vision videos for,
uh,
the creation of the new tour so you guys can creatively,
um,
being more connected to how I make things.
I'd be great.
Oh,
since we're at Google,
this question is apropos,
uh,
these run from in Chicago,
Illinois asks,
have you ever googled yourself just to see what came up?
Yes,
of course I have.
When was the last time?
The last time I probably,
uh,
well last night I wanted to know if people knew when I was going to be here
because everybody was telling me not to,
to
wait.
So I googled and I didn't see enough come up.
So I said,
well,
I'm tweeting.
Yeah,
I saw that problem.
And then,
mmm,
well you've got 443 million hits on Google for lady Gaga,
which basically means you don't have very much anonymity laughed at all.
And I guess pooky one,
two,
or three or four from Colorado asks,
are there ever moments the Paparazzi,
doesn't it
recognize you?
I have to be really honest.
People that stay and that they can't escape the Paparazzi are full of shit.
So
let me just be the artist to throw everybody under the bus.
My head of security standing over there nodding.
I don't spend money on houses and lots of cars,
but I do spend money on security and they never find me.
So,
uh,
no,
it doesn't run my life because,
uh,
getting my photo taken is not what makes me feel like an artist.
It's being in front of 50,000 fans screaming.
I was born this way,
baby.
That's why I'm here.
We have another video question from peach dog.
A one to two for the user names aren't great.
Stock keeps dog wants to know a little bit about regrets.
Okay.
Amen.
The Monster.
My name is Ben and my question for you is that in the song born this way that
you were used to at least,
which is awesome.
You have the lyrics that don't hide yourself in regret.
I was wondering if you have ever regretted anything or if there's something your
life that you'd ever want to change in the past.
Um,
thank you for looking at my question.
I really love you.
Thank you for making these.
Bye.
Is there anything that I regret from my past?
Um,
well,
I'll begin with the lyric and I will say,
don't hide yourself in regret is don't perpetuate negativity in your life.
Don't obsess about the things that you didn't do or the things that you may have
not done your best.
Obsess about the future,
obsessing about today.
Thank endlessly about how you can pull the inner queen or king out of yourself
and let that,
let that superstar shine.
I don't believe that famous something that is obtainable.
I believe that it's,
it's inside of you.
It's not something that you can touch.
It's not tangible,
which is why when I speak about the pop rocks and things,
it's very meaningless to me.
There are days when I wake up and I don't feel like a superstar.
And it's those regrets.
He say,
uh,
did you ever wake up and feel like a superstar?
The answer's no.
Uh,
the regret of some days me waking up and not feeling brave enough.
those are the regrets I have because I have so many things to be grateful for.
So many fans looking up to me and the days when I feel insecure,
those are my regrets.
I want to always be secure and strong for you because look at how speed they're
there.
They're so,
uh,
so genuine and they're listening to the lyrics,
you know?
And so I guess what I would say is don't,
don't obsess over what you've done wrong.
Always look into yourself and the answer and be the best you that you can be in
the future.
And in the same area.
I think it's
in the same vein.
We have a Christian for Australia.
What's the greatest piece of advice you've ever received?
It's the greatest piece of advice I've ever received.
It is.
If you don't have any shadows,
you're not standing in the light.
Hmm.
I say that to me
every day,
every single day.
I say that because I'm not a squeaky clean person,
you know?
So there's nothing about my music or the monster ball.
All my fans that were not squeaky clean.
Well,
you know,
when people always say to me,
who's the ring leader you when in reality we're pretty much an open book about
my life.
Uh,
what you're asking me about his magic.
And if you are magical,
you always have shallows in the light.
You must cast a shadow.
Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit about the new album.
It's out on May 23rd boring.
This winning the s the first thing and all the title singles already out.
It's been number one for five weeks already.
You done
and we have a video question about the new album.
So we'll go to jazz bridger here on video.
Okay.
Hi.
If you could describe the born this way album in just three words,
what would they be
in three words?
See how smart my fanzine?
Well,
I would call it,
I would,
well I would I Wendy's a,
it is one word.
I suppose that avant garde is one word,
but I would call it Avant Garde techno rock.
Okay.
Well
there's a lot of 'em.
It's Atlanta,
um,
rock influences on the album,
but not in a,
uh,
this is a rock music record kind of way.
It actually is quite steadfast and that it is an exploration and electronic
music and techno sonics.
But I have sort of created a genre of metal dance,
techno pop music with a lot of wrong anthemic courses.
Um,
because that is the music that I love.
I'm actually really obsessed with it.
Bruce Springsteen.
Um,
my father used to play,
we're Springsteen records for me all the time when I was a kid and he was,
um,
blue collar America.
And in a way,
I guess I related to Bruce because I watched my father,
a blue collar American citizen relate to Bruce.
And I think that in a social way,
my fans feel blue collar.
They feel like they're the underdogs that will someday be the winners.
And,
uh,
I took the influence of Bruce on my father in my life,
to create this album.
And uh,
yeah,
lots of really big,
almost like big def Leppard style melodies and the in the courses.
But,
uh,
it's electronic dance music.
It's very hard and very edgy.
Um,
and I'm very [inaudible].
I did it for you to hear it.
We're all looking forward to [inaudible].
One of the things that you face as an artist is censorship.
So Shane Rz 66 from Colorado asks,
how do you feel about Malaysian radio stations editing out your imperative,
no matter gay,
straight or bi lesbian,
transgendered lifeline from born this way?
Well,
obviously I disagree with it.
Otherwise I wouldn't have specifically put those words in a song that I knew
would be put on top 40 radio.
Um,
what I would say is for all of the young people in Malaysia that want those
words to be played on the radio,
it is your job and it is your duty as young people to have your voices heard.
You must do everything that you can.
If you want to be liberated by your society,
you must call.
You must not stop.
You must protest piece of lane.
Nobody.
I don't believe in violence.
I don't believe in negativity.
There's no reason to be derogatory.
You just have to keep fighting for what you believe in and to be quite honest,
honesty and the truth is always what will set you free.
I can't tell you how many times I get phone calls from TV stations and Troy will
call me and he'll say,
they want you to edit out this section of the video or,
and I say,
well just tell them I'm not doing it.
And if they don't want to play it,
they don't have to.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
artists is constantly loading ourselves and changing and bridging,
bridging what we do for the machine than the artists becomes part of the
machine.
I don't want to be part of the machine.
I want the machine to be part of me.
The next question,
the next question is actually a composite and we'll open up to actually to
Google or questions if you want to move to the microphones in just a minute.
Um,
is it your boss?
There were 643 fan questions asked about the next single but comes off of born
this way.
Judas.
And so I'm wondering if you can tell us a little bit about the inspiration for
it.
Um,
the video you have planned.
I'm very excited actually.
I can exclusively with zeal here.
I Google that.
I will be making my directorial debut with Lorianne Gibson directing this video
with her ourselves.
[inaudible]
surprise,
I'm sure to many of you that Judas is a man of the biblical senses.
Uh,
so,
um,
expect to see some symbolism in this video.
Uh,
but the song is about some of the words in the song like can prevail here are,
um,
when he comes to me,
I am ready.
I'll wash his feet with my hair if he needs forgive him when his tongue lies
through his brain.
Even after three times he betrays me,
I'll bring them down a king with no crown.
Uh,
so the song is about honoring your darkness in order to bring yourself into the
light.
Uh,
it's kind of what I just mentioned to you about if you're standing in the light,
you cast a shadow.
I have been haunted by my past for very,
very long time.
And actually that's a recurring theme on Elmo and has a lot to do.
I think with identity and being able to be proud and say I was born this way,
but I was haunted by being able to go back to New York.
Being able to go back to my past,
being able to understand why made certain decisions that instead of regretting
them,
I chose to embrace and understand why I made those choices.
And what the Song Judas about is about is you have to look into what's haunting
you and you need to learn to forgive yourself in order to move on or we all
looking
forward to
and it's really fun to dance to.
And it sounds like
a pop priest record.
It's really fun.
So we'll go ahead and take some questions from the audience.
Hi.
So I understand that the fame brought you a lot of great things like your
monsters and everything that's happening to you,
but is there something that the fame brought you that could do without
that I could do without?
Um,
I don't know.
No,
I would say no.
I don't want to focus on anything negative like that.
It's,
there's always,
whether you're famous or you're not,
there's always things in your life that you could do without.
So I don't think anything is particularly fame related.
I,
I've got a really good family and if anything,
I'm grateful because my family and I wrestled fame to the ground and we're
stronger than ever.
So,
uh,
so no.
Hi Lady Gaga.
Thanks so much for coming.
And I'm so cute.
A little background on this.
Um,
I took the inspiration from the Kermit the frog one.
Yeah.
It's how I added a little bit of myself in it.
They're bunnies.
So for eastern I thought it'd be a,
uh,
hoppin you know,
attire.
You liked that.
I liked it too funny.
Sorry,
what was that?
That's funny.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I,
I thought I had to,
you know,
dress up shoes.
I definitely wanted to speak to you and give you a hug or whatever.
Um,
but I think,
I think Google as a whole and youtube and the world is very excited for you to
come here and be so candid.
Um,
so on that note,
I'm disappointing,
you know,
really curious when you're not in the spotlight,
um,
when you're home,
you know,
in New York with your family,
um,
what are,
what are some of the things you enjoy doing?
Um,
what do you wear?
what are your pajamas look like?
Um,
um,
well I'm actually,
I'm very into yoga,
so I do a lot of that really cry.
I sound the yoga rooms here at big Pharma.
I'm not Google.
I was like,
it's ending my way,
but I'm actually really into that crazy hot yoga in hundred degree rooms.
Um,
it's the only thing that I can,
I feel can be really bad at and nobody knows.
So I sort of take comfort in the journey on becoming good at Yoga because,
uh,
if I suck at one day,
nobody sees it and it's just me.
And that's,
I guess that's the thing about fame that,
that is,
is difficult is if a screw up
Google
there.
Um,
I love,
I love Yoga.
I love cooking.
I'm a really good cook actually,
which means some of you may not know about me.
Um,
I love spending time with my mom.
I love getting really drunk with my friends at the same bars that we used to go
to and listening to ACDC records and,
um,
what else do,
what do I wear?
Um,
I mean,
to tell you the truth,
it's very funny because my father quite often it's like,
can't you just put on this or,
but
have you been to any of my shows out of curiosity?
No,
not yet.
You haven't yet?
Well,
I would say anyone that's seen me live would tell you that whether I'm dressed
like this or wearing a tee shirt,
I look the same.
And I know that that might sound silly,
but,
um,
it's not this that you are responding to anymore.
And I keep talking,
talking about this because my fans are actually quite blind to my clothes.
No,
because they're so used to it that they don't see it anymore.
They just see me.
And I'm excited about that because I think with this new album,
uh,
people will wonder less and less what I look like when I'm brushing my teeth.
But the truth is I look exactly like I look right now,
I just,
you know,
probably have a motley Crue tee shirt on and there's a really good looking guy
and my bed.
[inaudible]
well I think my manager is out on the road.
Well
anytime you want to come cook in or you know,
hanging out with my mom and you're more than welcome.
Well you asked for a hug.
So do you want to come up in here?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so cute.
That's a lot of bunnies.
so we'll take a few more questions here.
Hi,
my name is Logan.
Thank you so much for coming.
I Logan thrilled that you're here.
Hi.
Um,
I'm wondering,
have you seen the video called Friday by Rebecca Black?
No.
So this is the latest Internet sensation and it's this 13 year old girl who made
a video and now it's online and everyone's making fun of it and just kind of
criticizing it as really cheesy,
which it is.
But she's only 13 and my reaction to it,
or I'm curious about your reaction to youtube as a forum for new artists and for
some of the criticism that may be young people get for going online.
And then on the other side there's the Justin Biebers who are becoming famous
through youtube.
So what do you think about the future of fame through youtube?
I think it's fantastic.
I wrote back,
oh black is a genius.
And anyone that's telling her she's Chinsy is full of shit.
Okay.
Sorry.
Here
I got.
Thanks for coming.
Nice.
I think I've done the,
you know,
I don't want to laugh
because I'm quite certain that sometimes want to,
I enter the room.
That's how painful.
Well,
it's really good.
It kind of looks like the Chrysler building.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I used to be an architect.
So did you go to school at Carnegie Mellon?
Great.
Well,
I'm happy to I lenders to you for your concert.
Okay.
One of them Lanco quite well actually
it's all yours.
That might surmise serious question though is,
and we talk about Gaga,
this guy got out and the fame and the fame monster.
But what about Stephanie?
Like how do you stay Stephanie through,
I have this question.
Who are you living?
I'm right here.
Stephanie is also who I am.
God has just my nickname.
It's like when you're a kid and your mom calls you skip or
okay
calling you,
uh,
you know Johnny,
she calls you Jonathan.
And when you're,
when you're bad,
uh,
it's the same thing for me.
It's just,
it was a way for me to release so many years of being told no by this business.
And it's actually funny because I didn't,
um,
I didn't shop around to record labels until I was calling myself Gaga and until
people in New York knew me as lady Gaga,
but in high school and making music and choir and being Catholic and the boys
play and all the girls hated me because I always got the lead,
hated me for that cause it was at the boys' school.
So if you've got the lead,
they were always at the boys' school,
upper school.
So I guess what I'm trying to say is,
is I really make absolutely no separation between Stephanie and Gaga.
It is the absolute same person.
It's just,
it was a way for me in my life and I was in gift.
I wish I could give to anyone is if you went through hard times when you were a
kid or when you were in college or maybe you had a job that really,
and they fire and you and you were,
you were,
you know,
poor for two years and then you got any,
I wish I could give that gift to anyone of being able to say I will be unique,
all of that negativity and I am no a new person and I'm going to be the queen.
I know that I can be.
And that's really all that.
I bet it is.
Thanks.
I know you have it meticulously plan wardrobe,
but just in case I'm going to leave this.
Thank you very much.
We'll take
two days.
Leave all fashion accessories.
Ooh,
thank you.
I can't help but
it's not balancing very well.
Okay,
well no you weren't.
Oh,
thank you very much for coming.
[inaudible] so much of you music is,
as you kind of labeled it,
the Avant Garde techno rock and kind of lends itself towards this really epic
sound.
Um,
and then you,
you take those songs and you make these amazing acoustic versions that,
that are just as polar opposite in terms of the music.
How it,
and I was just wondering if you'd talk about the process of building those two
songs out of the same lyrics,
same notes,
same chords.
Um,
and is there one that you prefer like performing?
Oh,
well,
I guess what I would say is a lot of times and my songwriting process,
I will begin at the piano.
So I'll,
I will actually write one of the songs and they all along that is truly one of
my favorites.
It's called the edge of glory.
And,
uh,
it's kind of a sad story,
sorry to be a downer.
But my grandpa died about five months ago and my dad and I were going to say
goodbye to him at the hospice and I got out of big thing of a god way Tequila.
And my dad sat next to me at the piano and we just started doing shots back and
forth.
And I wrote the edge of Gloria and then piano.
My Dad and I cried.
And,
uh,
this song's about,
um,
your last moment on earth,
the moment of truth,
the edge of glory is that,
that moment right before you leave there.
Um,
so that song can be played on the piano,
but it's actually set to this giant,
huge techno rock,
Springsteen s Dan Speight.
I actually had Clarence Clemons from the e street band come out and play
saxophone on it.
It's fucking beautiful.
And I do that with a lot of my songs,
but it's,
it's,
it's funny,
it's so interesting to hear your perspective on it because that is really what I
wanted to do with this album as I wanted to show my abilities as a songwriter.
So a lot of the songs are like that.
There's really no song on the album that can't be played at a piano
acoustically.
It's all about the song writing.
It's all about my abilities as a writer from a melodic perspective.
And I coproduce produced every song on the album.
So,
uh,
sonically it just,
it just smells like me,
if that makes any sense.
So I guess what I'm trying to say is,
um,
in my opinion,
all good music can be played at a piano and still sound like a hit.
Thank you very much.
And one more question here.
Hi.
I'm Chris.
Hello.
Why do I
likes the movie were coaxed into doing this.
Yeah.
Cause we were promised we would get a prize if he's the best dressed.
Oh.
Hoping to win.
So you get 200 bucks.
I'm painting then those Bala,
the action
there.
What?
Loofahs Lupus.
Oh sorry.
Can I take my glasses up?
Yeah.
To take a really fancy shower then.
Okay.
Um,
okay.
So I've got to on my credits,
I'm nervous.
But um,
what I wanted to ask you after hearing you talk,
you have a very positive,
um,
look on life.
So I was just kind of wondering where that came from,
what happened in your life to shape that cause not many people are,
are like you and can always say rebuke things that are bad and you know,
always looked at it.
Good.
Well my mom has a really good mom.
She really was there for me and she always taught me to be very gracious.
My mother is the kind of person that won't give you the shirt off her back if
you're called a,
and that is how I was raised.
But I guess I would also say in it,
I don't know if people want be more religious.
And I always felt kind of awkward talking about religion because I don't want
people to feel like I'm impressing any kind of belief on you.
Um,
but I do see,
I do believe that God comes in many forms and I don't believe that we know what
he looks like.
That's something that I actually address and um,
and Judas,
but I see God in my fans.
So every night when I look into the audience,
I feel like I see this,
this force of beauty and,
and that,
I don't know,
it's just faith.
So I say faith and my fans and,
uh,
that's what keeps me strong as them,
as I really want to go out there.
That,
you know,
I don't,
I don't go out after this showing get plastered and do a ton of drugs.
And when I go on stage the next day,
I can barely sing.
You know,
I'm very,
very disciplined and hardworking and I am a,
as a book,
as a blonde woman with tits and ass.
Very proud of my accomplishments as a musician.
And I say that with,
with lots of strength.
Um,
people call it arrogance,
but I,
I do believe that women in pop music,
um,
have a very bad rap.
And I think people have learned to expect very little from all of us.
And it's very unfair.
It's a very prejudice.
So me and my tits and my ass and my brain,
I'm very proud to be here
today
and I truly,
I truly see that.
Thank
God and my fans,
they are,
they are who I worship is when I'm trying to say,
and I believe you worship in your life.
It doesn't have to be religion or an institution or a certain kind of God.
It's just you must worship your,
your faith.
I perhaps I am speaking,
uh,
and my own Gaga tongues,
but I worship my fans is what I'm trying to say.
They are.
They are my religion.
Hmm.
I love your music.
I love you too.
No.
[inaudible]
that's how that towel wrapping its game to me.
Like new Jerusalem to then,
so if I'm not mistaken,
next Monday,
March 28th is your 25th birthday.
Yes.
[inaudible]
happy birthday and meet you.
And you can tell him I just keep telling people I'm 24 we won't tell you who
light,
but we won't,
we have a surprise for you.
But you can tell that there's many people in the audience who are dressed up in
their best Gaga garb and we've handed cards to a few people.
So one of the people who came and got her card before the show come up and we're
going to have you the best lady Gaga.
You want to come on and come on here.
Hi.
Can I get those all of you?
That's really good.
Hello.
Thank you.
Hi.
Hello.
This is interesting.
It's very easy.
Sounded wrong in the 60s is an ammunition belt.
Wow.
That's heavy.
Nice boots.
Hi,
you look beautiful.
Hi.
You know what's so funny?
I was on my first record label go,
you can go back.
Sorry.
When I was on my first record label def jam,
not to bring up,
it's our story,
but I sent all of the employees and def jam disco balls that I pan painted
myself like that except I wrote his Gaga all over them and I sent them huge bags
of candy from the dollars.
But these disco balls,
it had my name on it and I got dropped like a month later.
But,
but I,
I remember someone called,
told me that everybody in the office was like,
who sent all these,
these gummy worms and just go blog.
The thing Gacaca,
I hadn't painted those suckers.
I mean one of them.
Okay,
well this is very good and this is very good because it looks almost exactly
like my Terry me and glare inspired outfit from the fame ball.
Very first fame ball.
This is amazing because it looks just like the telephone video.
However,
I have to say that the mark of a true Gaga fan is always thinking forward.
And that is you.
It's very,
very deep.
The pony tail looks perfect.
The,
uh,
the shoulder pads on that.
You,
you did a nice job with the duck tape
and that is exactly why it took me an hour to get my makeup done for that.
And it's 15 minutes.
That's a real glamour girl.
Well,
congratulations.
Okay.
No,
I got was performing O'quinn tonight.
So all of our cochair competition,
even here on stage,
we're all going to pair him tickets to the concert tonight.
And here you can have the riding car.
Really wonderful.
It's really what that actually,
that's set up guys.
I'm just to explain it a little bit.
Sure.
Wico who was in the video with me?
He has the same,
uh,
he's tattooed that way.
I read that last night.
Yes.
That's really,
he's really tend to that way.
And I asked him,
you know,
when we run the set,
I said,
why didn't,
why did you get,
it's kind of like a weird,
funny question,
but why did you touch yourself this way?
And he sent the Zuka Gung Ho.
I said,
what do you mean bazooka gum?
And he said,
well,
you know how busy it could come,
comes at the stick on tattoos.
He said,
I really liked them and I loved punk rock when I was a kid.
So I just used to listen to punk rock and put bazooka gum tattoos on.
So they touching my face like this.
So that's why we've,
we've,
uh,
chew bubblegum and the video.
Uh,
but I,
I wanted to tribute winco because,
um,
I believe what this look represented to me was that I will not allow,
society or critics dictate my beauty.
I,
I tell you what I believe is beautiful about me.
Every person defines their own beauty for themselves.
Uh,
so that's what,
uh,
makeup represents to me is that Waco was defining who he is in an artistic way
and not,
um,
relying on society to tell him what makes
valuable.
[inaudible]
so you look fabulous.
She's coming to the show.
Yes.
They were all coming to the show.
Right?
Right.
They are not the only people who are coming.
So we have 40 more on these cards taped to the bottom of seats.
So if you look under your seats,
you can get a pair of tickets.
Oh,
the Gaga concert tonight.
There are instructions on the back as to how did it go.
Cute.
And just school.
Lauren.
Lauren,
any phone number?
Yeah.
And just so no one leaves empty handed.
We actually have special edition.
Google goes Gaga tee shirts for everyone here they are in Bengazi in building 43
starting at three o'clock.
So there we're there now so you can stop by there on your way,
on your way and leaving.
And I just want to say a big thank you and thank you.
In the house of Gacaca,
are we good?
Been an unbelievable number of people here at Google who have helped out,
but mainly Andrew sholtee who was
on and are some of you don't know this.
My Andrew was an ra at third north where I went to college and he wrote me up
for drinking in my room
and she came to Google anyway,
so we go way back.
Okay.
I just want to say a huge thank you to you from all of us.
Andrew,
your fans.
Thank you so much for being here today.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
this is the manifest
of mother monster,
a government,
the alien territory and space.
A birth of magnificent and magical completions took place by the birth was not
finite.
It was infant
as the wombs numbered
and then my ptosis of the future began.
It was perceived that infamous moment in life,
it's not temple turn on
and thus began the beginning of the new ratings,
a race within the race of humanity,
a race which bears no prejudice,
no judgment,
but boundless freedom.
But on that same day as the eternal mother Hubbard in the multiverse,
another more terrifying birth took place.
The birth of evil,
and as she herself split into two,
rotating an agony between two ultimate forces.
The pendulum of choice began its dance.
It seems easy.
You imagine to gravitate instantly and unwaveringly towards good.
She,
how can I protect some things?
So conflict,
it doesn't matter if you love him or capital h I n
put your paws.
Mama told me when
we're almost too,
does she
have her
dad cause he made his birthday.
No
claim.
Don't be a drag queen.
You don't be a Grad.
Just be acclaimed.
Rejoice.
It's true.
Cool.
Sure.
Don't be a drag.
Just be a queen.
Whether you're broke on evergreen,
Yo,
black,
white page
disabilities,
them do outcast for leader teased week Joyce and love yourself today cause baby,
you were born this man at gay,
lesbian,
transgender.
Check baby.
I'm on the right track
baby.
Hey
Baby.
[inaudible].